alors jeais qu'on voit hier soir ce qui
s'est passé il est 20h9 on est en direct
justement dans une région russe au
dragestan Dr exactement 85% de la
population musulmane elle a
été il y a un aéroport qui a été pris
d'assaut par une foule de personnes
après l'annonce d'un vol provenant de
Tel Aviv regardez les images à
l'intérieur de l'aéroport c'est
complètement fou
regardez
[Applaudissements]
alors ce vol avait été repéré sur
l'application
telgram sur sur l'application et relayé
donc sur téégram par un groupe suivi par
plus de 65000 personnes selon un
médiarus après l'annonce de l'arrivée de
ce vol en provenant d'Israël des hommes
se sont d'abord rassemblés devant
l'aéroport pour vérifier des passeports
des personnes qui en sortai à la
recherche de citoyens israéliens
[Musique]
regardez
revenir làdessus et les assants sont
ensite ensite tenté de trouver partout
les moyens là où se trouv personnes
provenant de TelAviv leurs soupç sont
portés sur un bus garé sur un parking
protégé écoue leur
propos
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est après il y donc les
forces de l'ordre sont arrivées les
vidéos de les voitures de patrouille
sont rapidement arrivées sur les lieux
pour tenter de calmer la foume mais les
assaillants se sont attaqués à eux de
façon très
violente
[Applaudissements]
alors euh c'est fou ces images elles
sont incroyables et on me dit que le
grand Rabin du Dagestan affirme que les
400 familles vivants dans la République
musulmane devront probablement être
évacués prochainement on va revenir
là-dessus dans un instant on parlait de
ce qui s'est passé dans cette province
russe avec ses dire ils étaient combien
c'est hord de plusieurs centaines de de
gens qui se sont effectivement reés vers
l'aéroport on les a vu sur les images et
puis après sur la piste et sans la
présence d'esprit de l'équipage qui a
dit au passagers surtout n'ouvrez pas on
le voit derrière vous là ça aurait pu
être encore enfin ça aurait pu être
dramatique on aurait pu avoir un B dû
faire appel à la gare nationale russe
qui a envahi le tarmac et qui a procédé
à
l'arrestation des arrestations de façon
assez musclée
regardez
Gill quippelle ça c'est incroyable de
voir de de de telles images en 202 23 24
c'est c'est fou c'est fou oui al là on
est au Dagestan donc qui est une
république du Caucase qui est tout
proche de la tchenenie et de l'ingoui
qu'on connaî aussi parce qu'il y a eu
une guerre civile sur une base
religieuse terrible il a eu un jjihad
dans en un peu dans les années 90 comme
celui qui avaittu en Algérie qui avaittu
en en Égypte et également en Bosnie qui
a laissé énormément de squel on le sait
aussi parce que de nombreux tchenens
sont venus se réfugier en France et
notamment parmi lesquels les familles de
l'assassin de du professeur Dominique
Bernard et de Samuel paatti et le procès
qui se déroule en ce moment précisément
de l'assassinat de
l'Opéra perpétré également par an cheen
qui s'appelait monsieur zmov qui est
décédé dont on juge un complice présumé
donc on est dans une situation si vous
voulez où il y a un un une espèce de de
de résultante de très grande violence et
euh ce qui est frappant c'est que vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'explosionou
les autorités russes qui sont encore
très présentes en chechini là la là
pardon au Dagestan le Dagestan est une
fait partie de la Russie donc euh n'ont
pas réussi à empêcher une chose pareille
et on voit simplement qu'il y a eu
l'arrivée à la fin avec ce ce monsieur à
qui cherchait son passeport et qui
finalement on avait l'impression de
scène de pogrom d'une certaine façon
alors qu'est-ce est-ce qu'il y a un
rapport entre cela et ce qui s'est passé
le 7 octobre où des gens qui n'aiment
pas les Israéliens qui n'aiment pas les
juifs ou qui n'aiment pas les
Occidentaux ont eu le sentiment que
finalement c'était faisable c'était
facile on pouvait tuer au nom d'une
conception de la religion euh vous avez
entendu bon je pe ne connais pas le
Russe donc je ne sais pas que ce qui a
été dit en russe mais je connais l'arabe
les gens on CR tous les gens criaient
Allah Akbar c'est-à-dire Allah et le
plus grand brandissaiit des des drapeaux
palestiniens et euh on voit bien comment
c'est justement c'est ce que j'ai appelé
le malheureusement le djihadisme
d'atmosphère c'est-à-dire on voit sur
les réseaux sociaux on voit les images
des exactions qui ont eu lieu en à la
frontière
israello palestinienne au nord de Gaza
et d'une certaine façon on se sent fondé
à les reproduire si vous laissez c'est
l'exemplarité des réseaux sociaux qui
crée ça et qui se greffe sur une
situation où vous avez une violence en
foui qui caractérise le le sud du caucas
et dont nous faisons nous aussi les
frais à travers les les assassinat qu'on
a déploré du fait de TR ch chîn r Oui et
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
l'imbrication de tous les conflits et
sur le fait que justement il y avait
plus un seul un seul point ou plusieurs
États en l'occurrence là la diplomatie
russe accuse Kiev d'être derrière cette
manifestation
anti-juif donc on voit bien que là il y
a une volonté de de d'expliquer par le
conflit entre la Russie et l'Ukraine et
de mélanger tous les conflits ensemble
tout à fait et en fait si vous voulez le
le conflit ukrainien il faut bien voir
nous on a tendance à considérer que
c'est un conflit européen
mais le l'Ukraine et la Russie pardon du
Sud sont au bord de la mer Noire qui
fait partie de l'ensemble méditerranéen
qui parla destroit à Istanbul rejoint la
Méditerranée vous avez l'Arménie vous
avez les pays du Caucase pardon vous
avez le
l'Azerbaïdjan et donc toutes ces toutes
ces choses sont très profondément
imbriquées et pour ce qui est du conflit
Russo ukrainien par exemple vous avez du
côté russe euh des euh bataillons
cheetchen organisés par Monsieur Kadirov
qui est le président de la tetchenie
allié au russe et qui proclame le djihad
contre les Ukrainiens mais vous avez
aussi dans les rangs ukrainien ce qu'on
sait moins un certain nombre d'opposants
Tchen à Kadirov ce qui va fournir
justement à la Russie euh le
l'opportunité des propos que vous venez
de euh de relater alors c'est quelque
chose qui juste qui rend les choses
beaucoup plus qui rend les les la
situation beaucoup plus complexe parce
qu'on voit bien que n'importe qui peut
se saisir n'importe quoi et qui nous dit
que demain dans un pays européen on ne
peut pas avoir des scènes plus ou moins
du même ordre d'où l'inquiétude des
autorités d'où la volonté de calmer le
jeu de montrer que la situation en
France n'est pas la même que la
situation au Moyen-Orient et autant que
possible de relativ des choses pour
montrer que en France par exemple quel
que soi nos différences aux uns ou aux
autres ce qui nous rassemble est plus
important que ce qui nous divise et ça
c'est un message absolument fondamental
pour le maintien de la paix sociale dans
qui n'empêche pas le débat on peut être
tout à fait proalestinien pro israélien
ça ça fait partie de la liberté
d'opinion mais il y a eu un débat sur
l'interdiction des manifestations par
exemple et pro palestinienne alors le
préfet de police sétait forcé de faire
le distingo entre ce qui était d'un côté
des manifestations pour les droits des
Palestiniens ça c'est parfaitement
légitime commeons que le droit des
Israéliens tout ce qu'on veut c'est fa
partie de la liberté d'expression à
laquelle nous sommes attachés et des
manifestations qui elles soutenaient le
Hamas et pourquoi à la limite même
soutenir le Hamas mais dans la
circonstance actuelle c'est-à-dire ça
c'est interprété comme un soutien au
massacre que nous avons vu les 14
personnes qui ont été massacrées et du
coup ça peut avoir une force
d'incitation à faire la même chose ou
sen inspirer dans notre société
évidemment ça aucune administration
responsable ne peut le laisser faire
alors on va passer à l'histoire du jour
la semaine dernière